bueno pues amar y aclara la gente estaba
muy expectante silencio total escuchando
a todas estas palabras que dijo macro
aunque usted pues se resumió bastante
bastante bien y luego al final pues ese
ese momento siempre tan jubiloso al
escuchar a la marsellesa primero pues
luego en tornado por esta soprano pero
también pues por todos los aquí
presentes y esos aplausos al final pero
usted como bien lo decía como bien
resumió este discurso de manuel marco en
realidad parece todo el comienzo algo un
poco copiado a lo que ya él había dicho
en 2017 cuando reconoció no solamente a
los los votos de aquellas personas que
lo han apoyado a él a lo largo de esta
corta campaña pero también mencionar a
aquellas personas que votaron por él
para frenar el paso de la extrema
derecha al frenar el paso o su llegada
al elíseo y también hablar de los
votantes de marginal ven una vez más
explicando que no había que tipear los
ustedes ven en realidad el discurso de
hace cinco años es prácticamente igual
pero lo que cambia es cuando el habla de
esa reinvención esa reinvención de la
que él ya nos había hablado en ese mitin
de campaña en marsella donde él dice que
no se trata de cinco años más de
continuidad él dijo que él en realidad
no le interesaba hacer presidente cinco
años más para seguir haciendo lo mismo
sino de reinventarse y hoy pues ha hecho
ese llamado a una reinvención juntos y
un llamado a la unidad teniendo muy en
cuenta pues que estas elecciones dejan
muy en claro que hay un país dividido y
algunos pueden decir que es polarizado
pero en realidad aquí hay tres bandos
todo el digamos una parte las personas
que votaron por makro en esa derecha
pero también está pues la extrema
derecha de lópez más los votantes por
meloso y ahora claro el habla de esa
unidad porque sabe muy bien lo que viene
en las legislativas de hecho el partido
de los republicanos no perdió tiempo el
día de hoy y ya sacó su eslogan para
esas elecciones en donde decía ni ma
cronistas ni lepenista somos de centro y
de derecha así que esto ya pues se deja
el anuncio de lo que a hacer esa batalla
por las legislativas en el mes de junio